in this video we're going to go through
a few examples of setting up some
problems with constant acceleration so
we're not going to solve them we're just
going to look at what we know and what
the question is asking for and then
identify which one of these equations
over here will be the most useful for
helping us solve it so Before we jump
into the examples I want to say that it
is very important to to understand where
these equations come from to really
develop a strong understanding of
position and velocity and acceleration
and time and how they're all related to
one another and Sal has a lot of videos
that go through that and and can help
you build that understanding but once
you have that understanding these
equations are kind of like using a
calculator where they help you save time
it's important to to know how to add
subtract multiply and divide so you know
the calculator is doing when you use it
but once you understand that the
calculator is a really valuable tool and
and that's what these equations are like
they're tools that that we can use when
we when we understand where they come
from so with that out of the way let's
let's dive into our example here so the
question says a light rail commuter
train accelerates at a rate of one point
three five meters per second squared how
long does it take to reach its top speed
of 80 kilometers per hour starting from
rest all right so let's let's unpack
this and and see what it's saying so
let's just start at the beginning a
light rail commuter train accelerates at
a rate of one point three five meters
per second squared so that's pretty
direct it's just telling us what the
acceleration is so let's write that down
the acceleration is one point three five
meters per second squared all right
there's one thing okay so let's keep
going how long does it take to reach its
top speed of 80 kilometers per hour
starting from rest so that one's a
little bit more complicated there's more
going on in here
but if we just start at the beginning
and say how long does it take right that
by itself is a question there's some
more stuff afterward but that by itself
is just asking
about the time how long does it take all
right so let's let's note that by by
circling this time here we don't know
what it is yet but this is our question
whereas being asked about the time all
right so if we keep going here we get
all right how long does it take to reach
the it's top speed of 80 kilometers per
hour so that's saying its top speed is
80 kilometers per hour when it's done
speeding up it'll it'll be going at 80
kilometers per hour so that's the final
velocity or just our velocity at the
time here so that's 80 km/h 80 point
zero kilometers per hour and sometimes
you'll see see this right here written
as the sub F to really explicitly say
it's the final velocity so the notation
might vary in your physics class but so
whatever notation you use that's fine
but make sure to ask yourself what what
is this symbol really talking about so
anyway 80 km/h per hour okay
and so we have that and then if we keep
going it says starting from rest so that
that's saying that at the beginning when
it starts it's at rest which means it's
at it has zero zero for its initial
velocity it's just it's just sitting
there so let's fill that in that's zero
meters per second okay so we have
analyzed this question and we see that
actually the change in distance didn't
appear anywhere in this question it's
just just these four these four values
right here so let's see if we can look
at these equations and identify one that
that has all of these things and and
doesn't have Delta X since we don't know
Delta X N and we're not looking for it
either so we see these two have Delta X
here and so so we can we can rule those
out and this one also has two Delta X so
we can rule that out so that leaves this
one let's
it has has velocity the final velocity
here it has the initial velocity here
has acceleration here and then it also
has time which is what we're looking for
so we can use this we've we've figured
out that for this question right here we
can just use that top equation alright
and then and then to continue this we
would plug in numbers and then and then
solve for T and and see see what that
time indeed is so for this video we're
not going to actually go through that
we're just going to go through another
example of setting things up so let's go
down to this question right here while
entering a freeway a car accelerates
from rest at a rate of 2.40 meters per
second squared
for 12.0 seconds how far does the car
travel during those 12 seconds and what
is the car's final velocity so this one
actually asks two questions so let's
just let's just focus on on the first
one to begin with and l so let's see
what we know so while entering a freeway
a car accelerates from rest at a rate of
2.40 meters per second for 12 seconds so
there's a lot of information here in
this first sentence so let's let's see
it says accelerates from rest right here
accelerates from rest that tells us that
the initial velocity is zero right from
rest it wasn't it wasn't moving
initially it was at rest so let's write
that down this also just like the
previous example had an initial velocity
of zero meters per second that's not
always the case but it happens that in
these two examples it was so let's keep
going so it accelerates from rest at a
rate of two point four zero meters per
second squared so that's that's telling
us what the acceleration is two point
four zero meters per second squared so
let's write that down two point four
zero meters per second squared meters
per second squared and in all these
problems it's important to think about
whether something is moving in the
positive direction or in the negative
direction or if it's accelerating in the
positive direction or the negative Drive
it actually looks like for these
examples we've chosen everything is is
is moving in the positive direction and
accelerating in that same direction so
we won't have any negative signs pop up
but it is important to think about that
when you're doing these kinds of things
just just in case something is negative
and that does that does affect your
answer and what's going on but anyway so
so it's accelerating forward
everything's going in the same direction
so we're thinking of forward as the
positive direction and they're
accelerating that this this car is
accelerating at 2.4 meters per second
squared all right and it says also that
it's doing that for twelve point zero
seconds so we can write that down as
well twelve point zero seconds all right
so we know we know three things here and
and you'll find that in problems like
this that's the magic number once you
have three of these you can you can find
out the other pieces using these
equations but anyway so the first
question says how far does the car
travel during those twelve point zero
seconds well it's asking how far so
that's going to be the Delta X here this
change in position how far does it
travel during those twelve seconds
that's going to be this this value right
here so this is our question circle it
here so now notice we don't have this so
we can look for an equation that doesn't
have this this final velocity value in
it and then that will be an equation
that will hopefully have these other
four but we'll have to check that so
this one has that final velocity in it
so we can rule that out I see this one
also has the final velocity this one
doesn't have the final velocity so let's
look at that does it have so it has the
position the change in position that's
what we're looking for word has it right
there the or sorry the initial velocity
is right here so we have that as well
let's see it has time in it and we have
time so we will be able to plug that in
and then finally it also has
acceleration so it has everything we
need it has the thing we're looking for
and end it and it doesn't include
anything that we that we just don't know
that we're not even looking for so we
found that for this problem right here
this second equation here is going to be
the one that is most useful for asking
or answering the question how far does
the car travel during those 12 seconds
so that's that's for that question but
this this block here actually has a
second question maybe I'll switch to
green let's let's look at this question
what is the cars final velocity so all
right so that means we're looking for
this now right here what's this
well we've already identified these
these different pieces that we know and
if we did the first part of the problem
we would actually have a value 4 for
Delta X here but assuming we didn't we
didn't find that yet we could look at
this and say what's the corresponding
velocity I want to look for something
that has V in it and and has these other
three things that I know and if you look
and you check through here let's see
what is it so yeah I would actually end
up being this one again this is that
that equation that doesn't have the
change in position in it and so just
using the green color all I'll underline
this here to say that this equation is
useful for for this question and
actually now that now that we have this
value we could have used really any of
them that had had RV in it so some
options open up once we know more than
three different things but anyway
hopefully going through a couple of
these examples that will be helpful for
you and you run into your own questions
and have to think there okay what do I
have what am I looking for and then
which equation will help me move forward
in and solve this question